I just got that today just send it to me
that's pretty dead-on huh yeah anyway uh
so you were bullied so and they put the
multicolored stripes on your head to
represent your penis yeah they're good
they're fans they know so we you so at
15 you start taking martial art no
boxing boxing I started boxing it but in
Canada there's bullies in Canada yeah a
lot of it back then especially yeah you
know what are you same age as me how old
are you 47 I'm the same exact 46 there
you go we're the same age
we're the same guy if you got
demographic you know that's amazing so
yeah back then I was bullied too yeah
cuz they weren't sure of what we were
back I know who's still coming off the
wars yeah yeah you were just short after
the Korean meal all right yeah and they
also didn't teach like political
correctness back in the time so it's
like when I was in middle school kids
would still come up and do this oh yeah
you mean uncle open the refrigerator
pick up the coke or whatever that thing
was yeah was there and then there was
Chinese Japanese what are these yeah
what the [ __ ] is that all about
I don't know what that was you go up in
the Philippines yeah no you don't sound
like it Chinese Japanese and then the
Korean we'd split it really tight this
way Wow shots fired and we would say it
like Cory in sick bay hole yeah that's
the dry spit you would call Koreans in
chick Bailey :
yeah you guys hated Koreans huh no no we
like well now we sort of hate Koreans
they hate the Japanese for sure
historically speaking yeah yeah
currently the Koreans are just ravaging
yeah but you let them inside you didn't
yeah I do sometimes but only
multicolored ones yes what the color
diversity not any Korean dicks get in
there lavender dick Korean yes see you
loving to do
so you at 15 and then um and then you
and when you start doing stand-up
19 in 1989 start then then 1989 yes yes
yes 1980 [ __ ] nine you guys are the
same age but why didn't how did you get
to start so start at 19 start at 19 you
were wouldn't you start and I started
when I was 23 that's why Oh
you wasted time I but in what motivated
you I'd never seen my I told my mom I
had no career plans you know I was DJing
but and I loved it but there wasn't
enough money and there was better DJs
yeah and then I told my brother cuz he
was like well you know yeah at that age
that's when your family starts going hey
when do you think we're gonna do four
what do you think about doing for a
living yeah and you got to come up with
an answer and you don't really [ __ ]
know what you want to do I told my
brother I was like hey I don't know my
cousin Andrew kept telling me you're
funny he's good at comedy could you
stand up yeah all right so I told him
and then it was a girl let me take you
down so he took me didn't like go see a
Clayton did he keep took you down we're
down one night to go see like theater
sports which was like some oh yeah like
a hmm yeah yeah it's good but I don't
think that's the one for me and then he
took me to a yucky X to go see Amateur
Night
yeah when I was like ooh this seems more
like it and were you scared yeah I
didn't go on that first time I just went
watched cuz I was like I need to see
what it is cuz I'd already been
listening to stand by I'd seen it but
not like that and when you think about
it and you know you're gonna do it
eventually yeah it kind of shifts the
way you feel about life you you get
excited your body you can feel it in
your body right and you're also scared
and you have you feel feelings that you
normally didn't feel before more alive
almost you think you feel that if I felt
I felt in touch with what I heard like
when I heard the laughter I was like ooh
that's something I I may I dig that so
yeah you like that sound yeah and then
you did a do kill or no no yeah either
you know you get five minutes I think I
did three yeah and baled I was like oh
that's enough yeah yeah and then the
next time I think I did two and a half
yeah the first time I did that the my
thing came off yeah you know that little
core thing in the film to the ground and
I spent a minute trying to get the thing
into the pan right and I was eating it
like Oh sweating now when that happens I
know how to do it but back then you
don't know yeah Hannah it happened to me
what did this just happen to me this
weekend I picked up the mic and it just
fell right the drank too much yeah would
you play I was at wise guys in Utah I
play I love that room the new one right
yeah I just played it it's really your
entry from the green room to the stay
and there's almost people lookin outside
in the in with yeah it was really cold
really cold yeah and they're just out
there that's why that's why that gig
what happened what three months ago
that's why I quit smoking cigarettes did
you used to smoke a packet over a pack a
day breathe I know I know you've been uh
I know you've been sober for a long time
15 years 15 years but I was on that
stage and I couldn't [ __ ] breathe but
that had nothing to the smoke that had
no altitude I was the same way I know
but in my head I didn't know what the
altitude yeah I I was I'm walking around
going I the [ __ ] am I so tired yeah then
I go eh I said to my sister I said Eddie
I checked the altitude here oh it's
4,000 feet I go oh it's a thousand feet
less than Henry yeah we're just under a
mile up but imagine not knowing that and
you're walking around go I'm dying
[Music]